no ha habido una más numerosa en 2022
una nueva caravana de inmigrantes la
mayoría provenientes de centroamérica
venezuela y el caribe avanza hacia eeuu
siguen su camino al norte después de
permanecer durante meses parados en
tapachula una ciudad del estado de
chiapas fronteriza con guatemala todo
este trayecto acción duro puesto que
nosotros salimos de colombia como tal
por hobby
porque nos agredieron físicamente y
verbalmente
imágenes como éstas delatan la crisis
migratoria que atraviesa el continente
una que se exacerbó durante la pandemia
que degradó aún más las condiciones en
los países de origen toda salida a
luchar con la trabajo
nosotros los venezolanos somos personas
que siempre
salimos
de nuestro país mejor
los pasos de estos migrantes toman más
sentido en el marco de la cumbre de las
américas un encuentro que reúne a los
líderes de buena parte de los países del
continente en el que la migración es uno
de los temas más importantes a tratar
sin embargo son muchos los ausentes como
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador que no voy a asistir a la
compra siendo su país uno de los puntos
neurálgicos de la migración por el
continente según cifras oficiales méxico
ha recibido unas 50.000 solicitudes de
refugio en 2022 un 20 por ciento más que
durante el mismo periodo del año pasado